zuma est très protecteur quand je suis
mal que j'ai envie d'en finir avec la
vie
mais
c'est déjà aussi à rêver que j'ai des
voix qui m'ont dit de lui faire du mal
et malgré tout il reste à mes côtés et
l'a pas peur et me soutient beaucoup
d'un maladie et m'aide à combattre mais
j'hallucine à sion en est ridicule et on
n'était peut-être pas les angles si
j'entendais doigt qui me disait tu le ou
fellini mal
bah du coup
moi je m'imagine juge pas un méchant
slip
en fait ce soir qu'une hallucination
c'est ce que j'ai remarqué c'est quelque
chose qui se passe dans la tête avant
tout donc en fait c'est un travail à
faire sur soi mais en fait c'est de
tourner la chose à la ou positif aujourd
' hui ces jeunes c'est camille et on est
tous les deux à vingt six offres et nous
et on sait ensemble depuis cinq mois
camille et jason se sont rencontrés
grâce à une émission de télé dans
laquelle jason était venu parler de sa
maladie ému par son témoignage camilla
contacter sur les réseaux sociaux
d'abord meilleur ami ils sont tombés
amoureux qu'est ce qui t'a touché dans
son témoignage soit camille son courage
avait écrite maladie là faut beaucoup de
courage et je me suis reconnu dans ce
qu'il raconte est un moment de ma vie je
m'étais dit j'aurais jamais de copies je
suis un con et à sa camille ben je suis
content parce que je sais qu'elle va me
comprendre et même si elle s'en rend pas
compte il soutient beaucoup parce que
elle fait confiance et moi je lui fais
100% confiance parfois je suis pas assez
courageuse et jeu clairement envie de
mourir mais je reste en bas projet
jeunes font mes parents mon petit frère
parce que j'ai pas envie de la refaire
du mal oui
parfois je suis pas courageux monsieur
jason a été diagnostiquée à l'âge de 11
ans il y a trois ans il avait témoigné
pour brut afin de raconter sa maladie
depuis il a trouvé un service civique
dans une association où il intervient
auprès de jeunes pour prévenir les
addictions je suis stabilisé ça veut
dire qu'on est stabilisé quand on
estimerait en gros j'ai un traitement
qui fonctionne
jaugeant la maladie j'arrive à être
complètement autonome dans mon
traitement
j'ai une part est j'ai une vie on a
vraiment l'impression de fond n'est
contre qu'on est tout seul ça j'ai
vraiment appris à lire avec j'ai appris
allez c'est parti à des gens qui
pourraient me faire du mal je trouve que
j'ai pris de l'assurance
que j'ai évolué je m'exprime mieux je
trouve que bégaye mois en fait je suis
plus clair lorsque je dis j'ai acquis de
l'expérience
de son côté camille travaille dans un
atelier de réinsertion professionnelle
où elle fabrique des bijoux religieux
après des études de graphisme elle a été
diagnostiquée à 21 ans en fait ce que
j'ai très mal vécu c'est fait que ce
soit à vie et d'avoir un traitement à
vie si tu prends un traitement j'étais
malade
était malade se dire que différents un
des autres monnaies différentes
ouais
c'est à dire qu'il ya plus d'embûches
avec le temps ça passera moi pour ma
part mais vos amis me disent de me
suicider des fois je me vois pendu dans
un coin de la pièce la nuit gratuit dans
mon lit j'ai envie de m'arracher les
pareil les gens parce que j'ai des
douleurs fantômes en fête mètres du mont
blanc je dors très mal j'ai une
entreprise très compréhensif à part vous
arrêt de travail ne partent pas exemple
quand j'ai trop d'hallucinations je suis
capable de prendre un travail démontrant
une semaine pour me reposer car
certaines entreprises qui comprennent
pas ce handicap là les gens ont peur
qu'on soit qu'on soit dangereux pour les
autres qu'on reçoit du tueur en série
selon l'inserm
six cent mille personnes seraient
atteintes de schizophrénie en france
aujourd'hui camille et jason ne vivent
pas dans la même ville et ne peuvent se
voir que le week-end ils aimeraient
s'installer rapidement ensemble et même
oui on veut enfants surtout que maman
j'avais 28 ans j'ai pas tout garder
voilà comment je me sens prêt les six
parents de demain elle venait à me dire
je suis enceinte honnêtement tendues
nous on m'a dit mon gros swell repéré
chez nos enfants si jamais il ya un
problème après c'est vrai il ya une part
d'hérédité
peut-être que notre enfant aura jamais
rien il sera complètement stable 4 faut
vraiment s'accrocher à la vie quoi ce
que la vie elle a tellement apporté elle
est dure mais en tout cas je trouve ça
vaut le coup le combat que j'ai fait
toutes les souffrances que j'ai eu eh
ben je trouve qu'elles ont quand même un
mail it parce que l'amour en dit plus
fort gros message c'est faux car faut
garder espoir